Hi and
welcome to educational technology.
My name is David Joyner and
I'm thrilled to bring you this course.
When we started this
program back in 2014,
I would have wondered if a course
like this was actually possible.
Most of our online courses
are built around their lectures.
And while conversations and
discussions do happen, they usually
aren't foundational to the course.
But when this course is taught on
campus, there are no lectures.
It's all discussions, conversations,
activities, project presentations.
There's nothing really that we can
pre-prepare, and so I would have
wondered if a course like this would
translate to the online environment.
And, in fact,
that was one of the main criticisms
that some people had of this program.
People said that you can't have a real
Master's program without a lot of
interaction between teachers and
students, but
you can't have that interaction online.
And so
they wondered if you could actually have
an effective online Master's program.
But then we started to actually
deliver our courses and
we found something interesting.
Not only could we have discussions
online that were as good as we have in
person, but
oftentimes they were actually better.
The structure of the online interface
gave students a lot of power to propose
and guide their own discussions,
and students responded to that ownership
by really making the classes better.
So it's really because of you
all that this class is here.
You all showed us that we could have
a class like this in an online program.
In this class, we're going to try and
push that envelope even further.
We're going to try and
build an entire class around those kinds
of interactions and conversations and
discussions without any
pre-prepared lecture material.
We're going to build the entire class
around a project to really try and
build something that's
a useful contribution to
the educational technology field.
We're looking forward to
seeing what you come up with.
And we're really excited to get started.